bonsoir gérald olivier des événements
inattendus on imagine que vous le
spécialiste des états unis vous devez
être à uhry de ventre devant votre
télévision voyant ces images de violence
devant ce capitole dans ce qu'ils
appellent la plus grande démocratie du
monde
oui alors attention à ce qu'on dit
attention à ce qu'on voit attention à ce
qui se passe et attention à ce qui est
derrière
alors on a vu on a entendu des le fait
qu'il y aurait eu des coups de feu qui
était échangé intérieur du capitole ce
qui est évidemment extrêmement grave
c'est extrêmement préoccupant les images
qu'on a de l'extérieur du capitole
pour moi ce n'est pas de la violence
même si même si les manifestations et
les manifestants ne devrait pas ainsi
investir cette maison encore que le
capitole techniquement après tout c'est
la maison du peuple
mais au-delà de cela pour moi ces
événements sont la manifestation
évidente d'une frustration qui a été
ignorée qui a été repoussée qui a été
bafoué pendant des semaines et des
semaines jeudi frustration des
supporters de trump parce que ils sont
convaincus il ya pas mal d'éléments qui
vont dans leur sens
ils sont convaincus que l'élection a été
le résultat de fraude que la victoire de
joe biden est il légitime et leurs
plaintes ont été totalement ignoré y
compris par les médias elles ont été
moqués par les démocrates qui ont dit
mauvais joueur elles ont été
délibérément ignorée par les médias et à
l'arrivée on a ce genre d'explosion
parce qu'aujourd'hui on est au dernier
jour d'un processus qui jusqu'à présent
se dérouler selon les règles
institutionnelles et là les règles
institutionnelles et bien elles ont
éclaté manifestement mais cette
frustration
elle a été entretenue elle a été
préparée je dirais même qu'elle a été
d'une certaine façon manipulés par des
gens qui ont prétendu que les électeurs
de trompes n'existait pas et qu'on
pouvait faire tout ce qu'on voulait avec
eux que trump était un personnage qui
n'était pas respectable
ce qui n'était pas légitime à la
présidence ça fait quatre ans que les
démocrates nous disent qu'il n'est pas
le président légitime
alors qu'il est parfaitement et qu'il
l'est encore aujourd'hui et alors que
son mandat se termine et que son
successeur est élu sur des lignes qui
sont très contestables et avec des
façons qui sont très contestables
eh bien on a cette explosion que je ne
justifie pas que je ne peux je n'admets
pas que je n'approuve pas et j'espère
qu'il n'y aura pas de victime ou que ça
n'ira pas au delà
la nuit risque d'être longue à
washington mais ce n'observe pour moi
c'est ce que les démocrates ont cherché
à obtenir depuis quatre ans et ils ont
tout fait pour c'est une analyse
effectivement à entendre et on y
reviendra il n'empêche gérald olivier
c'est vrai que sur les images à
l'extérieur du capitole les choses
semblent plus ou moins calme d'ailleurs
on apprend que la garde américaine
nationale américaine a été envoyé à
washington un couvre-feu a été établi
les choses sont quand même assez
importante
les médias américains rapportent qu'une
personne a été blessée par balle et elle
se trouve dans un état sérieux il ya
quelques images d'ailleurs qui circule
sur les réseaux sociaux ont des images
assez forte
on pouvait tout de même imaginer ce
genre de situation au capitole encore
une fois au coeur même de la démocratie
américaine
écoutez je ne veux pas reprendre ce que
je viens de dire
bon moi je me l'imaginais pas qu'il y
ait ce genre de dérapages parce que là
on est même on est même au delà du
dérapage et et ce sont des images
extrêmement préoccupante et extrêmement
je dirais blessantes difficile à
supporter contre quand on aime
démocratie américaine mais encore une
fois je regrette vraiment que les choses
en soient arrivés là et elle en soit
arrivé là parce que les supporters de
trump encore ont été arrêtés ont été
ignorés en permanence
ils ont été comme on dirait ge
décrédibiliser pendant quatre ans de
même que la politique du président et
ils se sont aperçus alary
et que l'élection se déroulait de façon
tout à fait contestable et de ce
populaire pardonnez moi parce
qu'effectivement on avait compris ce
message mais il ya quand même eu des
recours alors c'est vrai que les médias
américains
excepté fox news évidemment on était
trop trompé non s'en sont jamais cachés
mais il ya quand même eu des rencontres
judiciaire après cette élection rejetée
notamment par la cour suprême sauf
erreur de ma part donc ces recours
judiciaires ils ont bien eu lieu n'est
ce pas oui ils ont bien eu lieu
maintenant il est très difficile de
mettre en place un dossier légal en en
quelques en en quelques quelques jours
pour que une contestation soit accepté
surtout que et c'est très important la
plupart de ses recours ont été rejetés
sur des défauts de procédure et sur le
fait que même si le recours était été
acceptée il ne concerne pas un nombre de
votes suffisant pour inverser le
résultat vendant le dans l'état en
question
à partir de là ça servait à rien de
reconnaître la place puisque même si le
le plaintif avec en cause le résultat de
l'élection ne serait pas changé ce qu'il
ya c'est qu'on a un faisceau de deux je
dirais de comportement de
d'irrégularités de le plat une élection
qui laisse vraiment un goût très amer
donc voilà maintenant la justification
elle est là l'émotion elle est là mais
je ne tiens absolument pas à soutenir ce
qui est en train de se passer au
capitole c'est quelque chose qui ait
jamais vue aux états unis c'est quelque
chose qui va rester en terme d'image et
qui d'ailleurs va évidemment nuire à
donald trump parce que là le mandat de
donald trump sera résumée en quelques
images qu'on est en train de voir faut
pas qu'il se fasse d'illusions et donc
tout ce qui tout ce qui s'était passé
qui avait été positif pendant quatre ans
et bien s'effondre parce que justement
on à cela et je le répète je pense que
les démocrates ont travaillé sur
l'émotion merci gérald olivier fait du
problème de liaison merci en tout cas
d'avoir été avec nous
pour commenter ces événements qui se
déroulent en ce moment même à washington